era tutti ragazzi femmine dove sono
video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
sono qui con questa tizia bella che è
mia amica o semplicemente dirvi che
questo video con la curiosità
io mi sto ufficialmente perdendo qua
dentro
quindi vi lascio al video e me ne vado
ciao perfetto ragazzi si pronuncia un
gioco della madonna e non vedo veramente
l'ora di vedere che allora mental
tormenti son like experience we strongly
deva becco c'è scritto che se soffriamo
gli attacchi di cuore e loro non sono
responsabili se finiamo all'ospedale
però va bene dai ragazzi son pronto
powered by sta minkia me ne frega niente
voglio morire mentre al tormento
episodio 2 ma come quanti capitali già
sto gioco regala matsuda da dahlia ma
entriamo nell'oscurità per capire di che
morte dobbiamo morire prima ecco
perfetto e stato bello conoscervi allora
primo l'ho giocato 9 che storia lega che
cazz trovano bellissimo ma vai matti
lancio le chiavi la partenza beh non
stiamo entrando a silent hill vero no
perché c'è giusto leggermente un po di
nebbia di andro in altri plessi non me
ne frega dei titoli dai fatemi già fatti
miei morire a psicologica la loro xp
rienzi a tua madre horror experience
prova [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Musica]
faceva parte dei crediti di inizio gioco
dello spavento fantasy bene ragazzi e la
partenza è stata una fantasia quella
roba tra l'altro noi due siamo regalo
news e tre assieme a michael entrate
nella mia scuola sbaglio era più o meno
note tra lo stesso modo alla mattina
all'entrata di scuola mi ha eluso la
flash drive la torcia che fiducia si
occupi no no no no no no fermo cazzo
abbassati non ci posso credere dai
stronzi lo sapevo ciao zio bobby a terra
che ciao zio cosa è successo miei che la
portano ero bastardo così inizio i
corridoi qualcosa che si nasconde
nell'oscurità e dora l'esploratrice è
una roba invece che un cazzo e sauro non
rivuole l'anello karl karl stolt carlo e
lo stolto siamo fatto bene per essere un
gioco colloquio swift questo però
potranno farlo un po più male perché nei
giochi colloquio si devono mettere del
sangue per terra qual è il problema
mentale vostro zio otto notti che pezzi
come
non ho visto che il cazzo succede mi
sono pagato solo per l'audio cosa è
successo vado avanti
iron delle lame adesso ho capito a cazzo
devo spegnere la luce ham in chiava
ditelo prima ma [ __ ] in mezz'ora
che provava un outlook formi i fab four
c non cercarmi io sono perso per sempre
inteso in culo tutta la tua sorella vado
a stringermi la mano credo ve lo zio che
voi stringermi la mano vieni qua ma il
cazzo fa siamo abitò spaventato non
volevo scusami allora dove sto andando a
carpi tua madre dove sei potete fare
attenzione quando spostati i mobili per
cortesia che non
porta la [ __ ] tutta na [ __ ] tua
madre ti ammazzo la famiglia tutti i
criceti pure che cazzo è successo
[Musica]
ma chi cazzo era stop credo sia il primo
degli esponenti mi sono preso da un
casino di tempo almeno 21 ed hardy pin
tua madre ti paga le ossa le ossa ha
lanciato le ossa capiamoci bene vado a
comprare dei di biscotti capita se ci si
ho capito è passato avanti non hanno
schivato lo sfilato bye bye bye bye bye
porta tra gli ama 3 non urlare caso gli
store di sheen anima prime te devo
spegnere la luce per vedere lui perché
se tengo accesa vedo dove vado ma non
vedo lui no no no no no no no fermi se
coppa ha dato conto melo pubblico
ragazzi io in tutta sincerità vi dico
che entrai volentieri qua dentro ma c'è
del sangue che va di qua sentite è
permesso sono il postino sto portando la
posta se avete voglia c'è anche qua con
lo stralcio ma perché ogni volta che
entro in una porta mi chiudono ecco
adesso qua non ci entro [ __ ] deve
entrarci per forza vero sì ma cazzo stai
calmo ora la migliora ma mi spiegate
qual è l'obiettivo di affanculo
quest'anno giornali nato casa delle due
passi mi fai fare se non mi trovo bene
me ne torno a casa mia ma dimmi dove sei
sto giocando con dj liberdade senti non
me ne frega un cazzo di che cosa hai
visto ieri siamo farmi andare avanti non
si apresta porta ai soldi o merda non mi
ha preso da presa mi ha preso mi
appresto a è quello di prima i green ma
no è giusto se ciò seccato ragazzo è
giusto era il green credo cos'è sto roma
o mio dio sono delle lame non devo farmi
affettare perfetto non sanno proprio un
esperto ecco non posso semplicemente
abbassare le ginocchia che non mi
ucciderebbe comunque no
la cellula madre fa le bizze beh sai che
manca uno anche 1 secco no no merda
l'incavo una legale mancava una fan culo
tutto sì sì sì sì già fatto ragazzi di
otis tra però il cuore vabbè dai non è
male pensavo peggio
ma chi è che uccide agli scarpe cosa
mette contro gli sgabelli sto gioco e
non voglio sapere
madonna che lasagna hai mangiato zio un
cazzo c'è una nuda c'è una era quella
dell'altro episodio ciao bella come stai
sei sempre più bombata ma non so che
tipo da yamamay vendono i reggiseni sono
quei cose che ti metti sulle tette
ho capito ma c'è una nuda si sta facendo
una pipa sto tizio me ne vado è comunque
non voglio assistere fate voi godete voi
credo è 6 beh è incinta dalla messa a
noi implicata non incinta che bella la
tua gente veramente non ne frega un
cazzo
c'è una nuda si è sempre una nuda pre
libera stavolta ti amo kate ma come ti
amo kate ma che intese in culla in
questo senso sei stronzo di merda cos'è
pò troppi fantagenitori ragazzi dentro
la porta dai canea mia posso fare non da
energetica poi ma mi state facendo la
festa perché il mio compleanno
questa parte gli esseri polaria io
pensavo di essere fuori ma sono troppo
illuso per ragazzi guardate che roba è
tra che quello di guardi in giro non c'è
niente davanti ci sono due occhi rossi
che cazzo acciona leva cioè nelle note
carichi mazzo
spariti
no no no no no no no no no no no via via
via via via via via via via via via via
via via a piuttosto se continua stava ma
preferisco perdermi nell'antico egitto
da solo porca [ __ ] ma stavo scherzando